>>
THIS WEEKEND.
BOY HOW TIME FLIES.
TO COMMEMORATE THE PRESIDENT'S
AMERICA, WEST HOLLYWOOD,
HATS TO SEE WHAT PEOPLE THINK
ABOUT OUR COMMANDER IN CHIEF.
I TOLD YOU WE WOULD DO THIS.
>> THAT'S WHAT I'M TALKING
ABOUT.
I'M LOOKING TO SEE WHAT PEOPLE
THINK.
>> HE HAS DONE AN AMAZING JOB.
HE DID MORE IN ONIER THEN OBAMA
DID IN EIGHT YEARS.
>> I DON'T LIKE HIS VIBE.
>> WHAT DOES THE HAT SAY.
>> MAKE AMERICAN GREAT AGAIN.
>> HOW ABOUT THIS [BEEP] [BEEP]
[BEEP] HIS WALL.
I WILL TAKE IT DOWN IF I CAN.
>> WE'RE ASKING TPOEPBLGZ IN
WEST HOLLYWOOD HOW THEY FEEL
ABOUT PRESIDENT TRUMP'S FIRST
YEAR.
>> I THINK IT'S GREAT.
I KIND OF BACK HIM UP.
SOME OF WHAT HE SAYS.
NOT ON TWITTER.
I DON'T NECESSARILY AGREE WITH
THAT.
>> YOU READ HIS TWEETS.
>> YES.
>> YOU FEEL IT'S FUNNY.
>> I THINK IT'S FUNNY.
A LITTLE BIT.
THAT BLOWS EVERYTHING UP.
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK OF HIS
FIRST YEAR IN OFFICE.
>> I WILL PASS ON SPEAKING ON
THAT.
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT HIS
FIRST YEAR.
>> STELLAR.
STELLAR.
>> WHY NOT.
>> I DON'T WANT IT.
>> NO HAT.
OKAY.
ARE YOU SURE?
IT'S OFFICIAL.
A COLLECTOR'S ITEM.
>> [BEEP] TRUMP AND HIS
POLICIES.
>> IF YOU DESCRIBED PRESIDENT
TRUMP'S IN A YEAR OR SENTENCE
WHAT WOULD T-B?
>> DEFECTIVE.
>> WE'RE ASKING PEOPLE IN WEST
HOLLYWOOD HOW THEY FEEL ABOUT
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S FIRST YEAR.
>> UGGG.
>> ROUGH FOR EVERYONE.
I THINK THAT WE SHOULD COME
TOGETHER AS A COUNTRY AND
SUPPORT WHO WE HAVE IN OFFICE NO
MATTER WHAT.
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK OF THE
I THINK THREE YEAR WILL BE OVER
80% OF AMERICANS.
>> WHAT.
>> TAX CUTS.
>> I DON'T PAY TAXES [BEEP]
>> DID YOU WANT A HAT, SIR.
WHAT IS THAT GUY?
WAS HE --
>> I DON'T KNOW.
HE WASN'T STABLE.
>> WHAT?
>> HE WASN'T STABLE.
I DON'T KNOW IF HE WAS A MEMBER.
HE'S NOT STABLE.
HE HAD STRONG OPINIONS HE SHARED
WITH ME.
HE DIDN'T WANT A HAT SADLY.
MAYBE NEXT TIME WE GO BACK WE
CAN FIND HIM AGAIN.
I THINK HE REGRETS THE DECISION.
GREAT HATS.
>> I GIVE YOU A LOT OF CREDIT.
GO OUT, RIGHT IN THE MIDDLE --
>> HERE IS THE INTERESTING PART
TO ME THIS.
IS WEST HOLLYWOOD.
PRETTY LIBERAL CALIFORNIA WE'RE
TALKING  ABOUT.
A LOST PEOPLE LIKE THE
PRESIDENT.
THEY WERE LIKE, YA.
I LIKE THIS GUY.
I LIKE THE HONESTY.
HE DID MORE IN ONE YEAR THAN
OBAMA DID IN EIGHT YEARS.
I DIDN'T EXPECT.
THAT.
>> I WAS SHOCKED, SHOCKED.
I HAVE BEEN THERE A FEW TIMES AS
YOU KNOW.
ASKING FOLKS HOW THEY FELT ABOUT
IT.
THEY WEREN'T JUST TYPICAL PEOPLE
THAT THE LEFT WOULD SAY ARE
TRUMP SUPPORTERS.
THE DIVERSITY WAS ASTOUNDING.
THAT'S THE BEST KEPT SECRET IN
LOS ANGELES, CALIFORNIA.
THE CONSERVATIVES THERE ARE AND
DIVERSE TRUMP SUPPORTERS ARE,
REPUBLICANS ARE.
THAT'S WHAT THE LEFT DON'T WANT
YOU TO KNOW HOW DIVERSE WE ARE.
IF YOU AGREE WITH ME.
TRUMP POLES.
THERE ARE A CERTAIN GROUP OF
PEOPLE WHO WON'T ADMIT.
THEY LIKE TRUMP.
THEY LIKE HIS OUTSPOKENNESS AND
HIS ICONIC CLASS.
THEY LIKE THE ECONOMY AND
RESULTS.
ALL OF THE NOISE ISN'T GOING TO
AT WORK AND OFF OF FOOD STAMPS
AND BACK IN THE LABOR FORCE AND
NOT IN POVERTY.
>> EVEN THE ONES THAT SAID HE
DID A HORRIBLE JOB WHEUFPLT
COULDN'T GIVE ME AN EXAMPLE OF
HIS HORRIBLE JOB.
THEY AGAIN POINT TO HIS TWEETS
AND HIS TWEETS HURTING THEIR
FEELINGS.
WHEN I BROUGHT OUT SOME OF THE
EXAMPLES LIKE LAST WEEK ABOUT
THE INCREDIBLE IMPROVE PHEBTS
THE PRESIDENT IS MAKING TO THIS
COUNTRY FOR ALL AMERICANS.
THEY SEEM TO AGREE WITH ME.
THEY HAD TO BRING BACK THE
FEELINGS THEY DIDN'T LIKE HIM.
HE TWEETS.
>> THIS GUY WITH THE -- ARE WE
SENDING ENOUGH SECURITY OUT WITH
YOU.
YOU OKAY?
>> THE SECURITY IS EXCELLENT.
THEY'RE DOING A VERY GOOD JOB.
HAVE HIM EXPLAIN HIMSELF.
YOU CAN SEE HIS LANGUAGE WAS
COLORFUL.
AT THE END OF THE DAY I THINK
MAYBE WE REFORMED HIM A LITTLE
EXCITED.
GREAT WORK.